the midday Sun beats mercilessly upon
the Navajo Nation dump in Gap Arizona
dog towns teen searches the tire pile
for signs of life it's a race against
time the rubbers burning hot and there's
lots of territory to cover
Tom Corrigan of the Padonia Arizona
Humane Society and dog town vet dr.
Patti I am Pedro catch a glimpse of
something moving in the tires the little
black fuzz ball that we pulled screaming
and kicking and biting out of a pile of
tires very very scared almost what I
would consider feral
like many reservation dogs this one's
likely a mix of a few breeds we're
talking probably an eight or nine week
old puppy that's left in a dump and a
pile of tires to fend for herself so I
don't know what her outcome would have
been had we not gone there and saved her
the team continues to look where they
see something under a couch it's not
moving careful the other one freaked out
the dogs in serious medical distress it
doesn't move or even make a sound it is
concerning especially considering the
other one was very not quiet if so I'm
just gonna give that puppy a little bit
of time in the van and see if he wants
to eat or drink anything the rough skin
texture and dry nose reveals serious
dehydration it's critical to get the
young dog back to the clinic quickly to
prevent organ failure before departing
this unforgiving landscape the team
leaves food and water for any other
animals in need